luke mom tom nate and jake here with the
outdoor boys youtube channel and we're
here in missoula montana with blackfoot
outfitters and we are about to go on a
two-day floating fishing camping
adventure you guys ready
let me introduce you to our guides here
we've got chad and kurt here who have
both bitten off more than they can chew
hop in the truck
no no jake where are you going
so what kind of trout they got in the
river we got some rainbows brown trout
cut bows white fish and bull trout
cool you excited babe yeah oh good well
you give this to me fun
this is gonna be pretty awesome and we
get mom to come along with us too i mean
what what did we do right to get that to
happen
all right guys we're at the blackfoot
river here in northwestern montana we're
just a little bit away from missoula and
this is my first time ever fishing in
montana it's kind of the fly fishing
mecca it's gonna be fun well right now
montana is in the middle of a heat wave
and there's tons of forest fires around
this area so the sky is a little bit
smoky and the water's running really hot
which is not good for trout
but you know what i've got a good vibe i
think things are gonna work out just
fine and we're doing a camp out with the
family so i mean we're gonna have fun no
matter what
how's this for a boat ramp have you guys
ever seen a boat ramp like this
and that's how you launch a boat in
montana
got the pepper spray for the kids you
can't shoot them and they don't listen
so you know
tom you look serious yeah you've been
wanting to learn how to fly fish a lot
haven't you orbis clear what kind of
flies are those that's a chubby a chubby
yep golden chubby
tan chubby got some droppers on here
like spanish what bullet spanish bullet
yep so for those of you guys who don't
know a dropper is when you have two
hooks on the same line and one of them
goes down a little bit deeper than the
other one so you kind of call it a
dropper in fly fishing you often use
droppers when you kind of have two flies
that you know work really well and you
want to see which one the fish are
hitting more that day
yeah hold on tight
oh my goodness this is just gorgeous i
love being in these boats you know
catching the fish is just frosted on top
of the cake when you're out here on
these rivers
you come up one two
because you want your line to straighten
out behind you before you go forward all
right we're gonna get tommy fly fishing
here he's been chomping at the bit to do
this
there you go that's the oh
shoot
yeah a hit he came up for the top one
good perfect man
there's mama and company coming down the
river how you guys doing you guys catch
anything we're like one hour into the
trip and becca is already out fishing me
she has two trout
look at that look how good looking she
is over there
oh there we go that's a fish there you
go oh that's a nice that feels nice
beautiful rainbow
oh look at that isn't that gorgeous
oh that's pretty hey all right
my very first montana trout beautiful
rainbow
i've just caught one i bought
becca's landing one right now
anything i can do she can do better
mom kind of trout that big
she's so out fishing here
you got four
i actually helped it
did you caught one day yeah
nathan what kind of fish did you catch
white fish how big was it
awesome i have zero surprise at all i
mean if you were a rainbow trout who
would you rather be caught by exactly
caught me that's for sure i have to tell
you i see why people like fly fishing
this is fun
the world is your toilet if you just
believe
becca's got another one
whoa
wasn't pretty but i got the second one
becca is tearing him up i'm just
watching her land him over here she's
she's a natural
oh you ready oh there we go
oh god don't don't don't don't just go
just please have mercy
tommy's trying to garat me for my fish
oh i've got a white fish on here i've
never caught a white fish before
there you go oh new species of fish
there he goes look at that
beautiful fish
i'm no becca but that's three fish you
know get some more light out there bud
guys if you're looking for a family
adventure on the water this is one of
the best options out there spent a lot
of time looking at white water rafting
trips and various pack trips and so
often there's really stringent age
restrictions so being out here with a
three-year-old a six-year-old an
eight-year-old and being able to take
them on the water and go fishing and
camping
and having people who are really good at
just you know working with kids and
stuff like that it's it's a big deal and
it's hard to find
oh there we go
becca's got another one
oh i asked how many fish she had she's
getting uncertain holding up both hands
oh that's a brown trout
oh my first round
i've wanted to catch a brown trout for
years
look at that that is just
gorgeous i have tried to catch brown
trout for years and been on three
different trips and got skunked or
caught only rainbows is that's awesome
that's awesome it's good i'm setting
goals like this because if i try to out
fish back i'll just end in
disappointment
[Music]
tear them off aren't you oh my god
okay thomas you see this little green
water right down here yeah that fast
water we're gonna cast right in there
when we get down to it
hey thomas
you want to switch seats and you be in
the front
oh that's a nice one tom
all right tom keep the rod high over
there just like with catfish there you
go there you go that's the biggest white
fish of the day tom
you want to try to hold on
i caught one beautiful
biggest white fish of the boat whoa all
right let me see all right film it put
it lock time put
there he goes there he is a little bit
a little muskrat or is that me
the mink yeah well there we go tommy
just landed his first white fish and it
was a monster and shortly after that we
had a meek swim under the boat so we've
uh seen some bald eagles a marmot mink
you know
this is a great float trip tommy you hit
the chocolate milk
you've caught two nathan
all by yourself
oh guys you got a big one
it's hard to fish with an earshot of
becca it's it's a little down hardening
becca my fishing queen how are you doing
that's incredible babe and nathan you're
doing great it is a beautiful day and
time to stop for a little bit of lunch
you guys sound good guys
these wonderful gentlemen here are gonna
get things ready and i'm gonna throw a
fly out just a little bit while i wait
the weather's just been about as good as
we could have hoped
we're having a great time everyone's
catching fish
and most importantly i haven't had to do
any of the setup stuff
it's great
hey you my little otter baby what are
you up to
all right let's go get some lunch guys
this is quite the spread this is quite
different
it's a little hollow though oh yeah i'll
take it on the freeway
it's a good sandwich
like watching a suckling pig
nothing like out fishing everyone else
combined to give you an appetite huh
there you go got a little rainstorm
coming in a little wind kicking up
gotta get the boys all bundled up
keep my potato chips from getting soggy
i don't know if i'm just extra hungry or
what but that was one of the best
tasting meals i've had in a long time
well you look very fashionable in your
grundens why thank you
yeah i told you i didn't need to take a
shower yesterday real good
here tom
you use the reel you can use the reel on
this one it's like a trout
no it's not a white fish
high five second fish nice look at that
that's my reward for all the good
casters i did yeah yeah
there you go
goodbye rainbow i think the 5 a.m wake
time has got to jacob he's out passed
out on your mom's seat
maybe i look good
oh yep he's just passed out right in
there
there goes mom ripping them in one after
another with two unconscious children in
the boat i tell you for fishing this has
just been perfect you know it's been
overcast a little
little drizzle to cool the water down i
mean it's what you need in the
summertime
feeling like a pretty decent fish
nice
dad thank you it reminds me of a
grilling a little bit you know they're
body fat mama's got another one what is
that is that trout
oh a nice cutthroat you're you're not
gonna leave me for a better fisherman
are you
yeah just pull the rod tip up a little
bit there you go flip it lift it that's
the fish
always keep the line tight all the ways
always always good fish let him run oh
what well you think it's a snag and then
the snag starts going upstream that's a
good fish
oh tom my heart breaks for you bud
oh
even though i did catch it i was like
that's totally awesome
that was trout zilla
oh
sucked it right off the surface
oh what is the throat oh
don't screw it up
woohoo my first cut throat in over 20
years
look at that the light orange on us
honestly oh beautiful fish you're
getting back in there
oh on the surface just watch oh
come up and nail it then me try to play
it and turn my camera on all the same
time
oh there we go
oh dang it he popped off buddies
you got him
keep it in your fingers
lift that rod too oh oh
my goodness do you see how high he goes
there he is
that is 100 all by yourself
that was a rainbow
that is a beautiful rainbow
that was amazingly high do you feel like
jumping yeah we gotta show that to mom
yes tommy you did it how does it feel
yeah it does
oh there we go
oh
and he's off lift it that's a fish oh
dummy
that that looks like a ginormous white
fish that might be the biggest white
fish ever caught in north america
okay he's going back in he's been out
too long
there you go
he hooked up
with a big one too he got away and i
thought out of the boat but
but only a little
get that rod tip up look at that
oh my gosh oh my god
why
look at that tommy well that's number
four
seven tommy's finally figured it out and
he's kicked it into overdrive i'm
catching up on you i'm catching up on
you
i used to do this to my dad
okay you're ready
thomas get another one
drop dude get that rod
i think chad just saved my life i almost
got killed by cut throat oh beauty
amazing
thomas
you're rocking me man
all right guys so we're coming up on
belmont creek which if you read the book
river runs through it
that's where part of the book comes from
oh
god
[Music]
hey
you look down the river and see back on
the other boat at the campsite so i
think we're about to have dinner
this is number 23 according to my math
yeah he's pushing 20 inches
look at that
let him go
see if he goes
back
that counts as six fish tom because he
was so big so i think i'm ahead now
no
i had four on and i landed uh
sir
rebecca how many fish did you catch i
landed 14 i had nine on that i did not
land jacob are you having fun yeah
well i guess i won't be needing let's uh
let's check out the camp set up oh they
have snacks out do you have snacks
look at this
look at this kitchen area this is legit
oh
got
got a little foot pump sink here
yeah
good dining room
have to wait for it to come back up
the bucket ball on the bottom has got
the fresh water and the bucket on the
top with the dirty water you know i just
realized that camping's a whole lot more
fun when you walk into the woods and
someone else has set up everything and
is doing all the cooking they have a
camping toilet
so mama you got to do some painting i am
i just need to find a spot good for you
i don't know about you but that looks
like a great painting scene right there
i was thinking too and that clip right
there is cool
i just need to plop down and not fall on
my head so don't fall down
there we go
we're at the top
hello down there hey boys come on it's
dinner's ready come on
it looks really good though
hey becca did you want did you want any
seasoning spice hot sauce i'm good i'm
good you're good of course i always i
always get greedy with my tacos and then
you can't fold them up
nathan chewing your mouth closed you
like watching an anaconda eat yeah are
you having a fun time babe i'm having a
great time this is really fun turns out
i like fly fishing
and this is your kind of camping too
isn't it it's my kind of camping this is
fun well i tell you guys it is just
wonderful have a belly full of tacos
some clean clothes to pull up off the
river after an awesome day of fishing
and have camp all set up it's really
really nice and becca is having such a
great time which that makes me really
happy you know she was willing to go
along with this for my sake but she
she was very apprehensive about this
trip but
just she's had i think more fun than
anybody else it's just been absolutely
wonderful
i saw some sort of cake-like substance
angel food
this is so much better than sleeping in
the snow under a lean-to oh that looks
good you like angel food cake a lot
don't you
you're wearing most your whipped cream
okay
all right guys so i know becca's gonna
want a pillow so i am going to make one
using the stuff sack guys
just take
your fluffiest clothes
switch them all in a stuff sack
and boom
you got a pillow
water rinse clorox i gotcha hey becca
this is a lot better system than throw
everything in a bag and help you take
care of it when i get home
you like that huh yeah
show me
i did a little sketch
it's wonderful becca it's been a lovely
day but i'm exhausted
kids have been up since 5 5 30. so uh we
got them all tucked in here in the tent
they're watching a really weird japanese
cartoon you guys like your movie yes
well hopefully they're gonna zonk out
here soon and me and becca get to relax
for a few minutes well guys it's been a
wonderful day but it's late and time for
me and back to get to bed so uh we'll
check in with you guys in the morning
see you then
oh
good morning do you wish mommy would
come on more camping trips yeah
[Applause]
oh this is gorgeous
but i can really get used to waking up
and having other people cooking
breakfast
this is this is nice
yeah oh we got some melon some
grapefruit some juice
she runs out of the store you get used
to this kind of camping couldn't you
pretty nice
that looks like real bacon too that
doesn't look like it's made right in
missoula are you guys sword fighting
that's fighting oh my god that's
happening you make me disarm oh they
have real maple syrup this is really
good good breakfast isn't it oh that was
delicious
oh sweet mama's packing lunches
if you're washing dishes then you catch
more fish
ready to be out fished by mom
tom you were red hot by the time we got
done yesterday
you ready to rock and roll
oh
oh there we go
oh beautiful back on the head of you the
only time today that'll happen
oh nathan's got a fish oh that looks
good oh that's a nice fish bud the giant
cutthroat pretty fish look at that giant
cut throat
there we go
all right becca has another massive
trout over there
a cutthroat
oh jeez that's a nice cut throat
oh
nice one
nice one
oh thomas nice
oh i got one
there we go
oh nice beautiful little trout
check it out it's white water sherpa
extraordinaire robert
making it look easy robert
i'll do that
these little current lines coming in as
we go across got a bald eagle right
there
or is my boy say a bald butt eagle
because their butt and their head is
both bald
jacob
again bees love to sting jacob i think
it's those cute little cheeks
got yourself a child is that a brown
trout tom
tom's got a brown drought
frown drowned
way to go tommy give it tight keep it
tight tom
you know bigger is pretty nice we go on
a fishing trip and we get a white water
rafting trip and a camping trip and
all that stuff all rolled into one looks
like we picked up a hitchhiker
nathan have you having a fun time yeah
oh i saw the flash i got him
whoo
becca you got one too
sweet i got uh two rainbows and i did it
one-handed while filming so yeah tell
you what becca looks so pro over there
[ __ ] her form is good
i've just seen becca like hook four or
five fish in the last five minutes she's
on fire
i'm doing great oh my goodness what
great fishing but we're gonna stop and
uh eat some lunch and before we keep on
heading down the river i'm excited to
brag to my family about what an awesome
fly fisher
i uh married oh
do you feel a little better buddy
love you becca thank you for the
sandwich
and i'll take it out
ah a little sandwich in my belly fun
little break a little bit of food is
nice
there you go buddy
give your give a rod tip up today
oh
yeah
oh my god
rainbow trout nathan
good job all right little rainbow
oh that's looks like a big trout is it i
think oh
oh guys that was so much fun but all
good things must come to an end
hey becca was that fun
nate nathan's out
figured becca caught slightly more than
half of all the fish caught
[Laughter]
but yeah we got about 50 fish that's
awesome
that's so much better than i was
expecting guys this was so much fun if
you're ever in montana want to do one of
these camping fishing trips check out
blackfoot river outfitters i'll put a
link down in the video description below
to their information so definitely check
that out this is a really fun trip and
if you guys want to see more videos like
this check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel don't forget to click subscribe
we put out new videos every saturday
morning and i'll put a link to our
playlist our camping adventure and our
travel adventure playlist down below
thanks for watching guys
click subscribe
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]